I'm only getting started Jack Black
shutting down rumors he's retiring from
acting I don't know whether it's big
news in a new video obtained by et Jack
responds to his recent interview with
balance magazine where he admits he's
thinking about stepping away from the
spotlight to spend more time with his
family and he's looking to make more
music with his band tenacious d my
partner's very jealous is he if he finds
out I got a new band with Nick Jonas
heads will roll he also told the mag
quote maybe one more movie I'm kind of
enjoying the idea of early retirement
I'm looking to wrap it up pretty soon
right off into the sunset clearly that's
not the case I'm not going anywhere you
heard the man Jack's a new action film
Jumanji the next level is set to release
this holiday season and when et sat down
with the 50 year old actor last month he
joked about the physical demands of
making the sequel it's a very physical
demanding movie every scene in every
location that it presented its own
challenges if you've never tried to run
through a sand dune then you don't know
the torture the special torture that
that really is it's impossible and yeah
we were doing a lot of a lot of ankle
twisting situations but we prevailed
[Music]